Modoc is finally in the MCU so why are
some Marvel fans so grumpy about it it's
hard out there when you're just a head
in a chair audiences around the world
will soon get an up close and personal
look at the quantum realm in Ant-Man and
the lost quantumania as the new trailer
dropped on January 10th reveals Scott
lying is whisked once again into this
bizarre and fascinating pocket Dimension
where he's greeted by alien Landscapes
and some imposing new characters the
major villain of quantumania is Kang the
Conqueror but there's also another
famous Marvel villain lurking in the
background in the new trailer modok who
has long been speculated to have a role
in the movie I'm a big deal I I just
fought Iron Man I stole his boot comic
book aficionados or fans of the Hulu
show know that Modoc stands for mental
organism designed only for killing and
he has a rather distinct look modak is
essentially a giant head wrapped in
advanced robotics with tiny almost
vestigial limbs by no means does that
make Modoc a pushover and although his
physical form is peculiar his mental
prowess is more than capable of giving
superheroes a run for their money modok
was originally a human technician named
George Tarleton who was transformed by
the villainous organization known as aim
or Advanced idea mechanics however it
seems as if Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania is taking a slightly
different approach to the source
material and bringing back ant-man's
original movie foam aim has already been
brought up in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in Iron Man 3 as the think tank
for Aldrich Killian Advanced idea
mechanics or aim for sure to get it I
see that because it's on your T-shirt ah
plus Tarleton hasn't shown up so it
seems as if Modoc will instead be Darren
Cross or at least some variation of the
character when audiences last Saw cross
he was battling Ant-Man at the end of
the first Ant-Man movie but cross was
eventually defeated and shrunk down to
nothingness or at least was assumed now
that the second trailer for Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania is out it seems as
if fans finally know what happened to
cross after that battle as he is spotted
hovering behind Kang as the iconic
villain when it comes to the nature and
look of Modoc it seems like fans are
already fiercely divided in opinions of
the big screen version of this famous
villain and have converged on Twitter to
let loose a mighty Deluge of thoughts
and comments on the negative side of
opinions one viewer wrote I hate modoc's
design with a passion look at him I
can't stop laughing he's giving frog
face unmasked another fan had some
strong words posting why did you give us
the ugly ass George Lopez modak instead
of the Marvel's Avengers cooler version
of Modoc this is a reference to Lopez's
character Mr Electric from The
Adventures of Sharkboy and Lavagirl who
also Sports a bulbous head and was noted
several times in fan comments on the
flip side there are some fans who
absolutely love the Modoc in Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania so what are their
thoughts one fan of the new look tweeted
I don't care I love what they're doing
with Modoc these movies are adaptations
let them adapt stuff not everything
needs to be comic accurate one Marvel
fan posted side-by-side images of the
character from the movie and the comics
and added all y'all who are dogging on
Marvel for modoc's design I just have
one question how the hell were Marvel
supposed to make this design not look
strange in live action with the Deluge
of comments that are both for and
against this new version of Modoc it
will be interesting to see what opinions
look like when Quantum Mania finally
premieres and the dust settles on the
divisive Giant floating head
foreign